there was no sign of the trouble hanging
over the prince's foundation as he
launched another new project at dumfries
house last week where the charity is
based but six days later two staff have
now opted to go after more claims of
rogue activity around fundraising
chair douglas connell has resigned
saying he had no knowledge of the
allegations but felt that the person
chairing any organization should take
responsibility if it appears that
serious misconduct may have taken place
chris martin executive director of
development is also stepping down
temporarily while internal
investigations are carried out but after
weeks of claims there are calls for even
greater transparency what i would say to
those who are looking at this
independently
is
you know look at this without fear or
favor
and i hope they will
the fact that allegations are made
against prince charles personally is is
not massive they should take into
account nobody is above the law
including prince charles
the first to temporarily leave his post
was chief executive michael fawcett one
of charles's longest standing and most
trusted advisors accused of promising to
help with bids for honours and
citizenship in exchange for charity
donations
last week as charles and camilla just
got on with the job there wasn't a sense
this is damaging his public reputation
in the way other scandals have done
laura clancy is a lecturer and author
her latest book dissects how the royals
manage their image charities are really
important in promoting the royal family
in promoting the monarchy and so it's
really important for giving them
positive publicity it's really
interesting that this has kind of come
out in such a negative way when normally
their charities are constructed as
something that should be celebrated the
palace continued to distance the prince
from the organization but look at the
website there is only one figurehead and
as the investigations continue this
remains a charity run under the name of
the heir to the throne rhiannon mills
sky news